do you know what the realm is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight breakdown video today I will be
taking a look at Game of Thrones season
8 episode 3 which is called the long
night as we all know this was set up to
be the biggest battle in television
history
they spent fifty five nights filming the
battle after Winterfell set in Belfast
Northern Ireland I don't know how many
of you did watch the behind the scenes
footage of them filming the battle but
what the cast and crew were able to do
was incredible regardless of how you
felt about the episode you can't deny
the amount of work that goes into the
show it really is amazing how they are
able to bring a medieval fantasy story
to life by using today's technology now
as dark as this episode was I also
thought there were some really gorgeous
shots in some of these scenes one of my
favorites has to be when we can see the
dragons flying up above the clouds when
the moon was in the background that
looked incredible winterfell's God's
wood also looked incredible when the
moonlight was shining through the
weirwood tree I also really liked when
Daenerys tried to burn the night king
with her dragon that was a really
terrifying image of the night King
surrounded by the dragon fire I also did
happen to like the new look they gave
the night king now maybe it was just the
settings on my TV but the night King
looked extra vibrant in the episode the
first time I did watch the episode most
of the scenes were too dark for me to
see everything that was happening but
then I watched it for a second time on
my OLED TV and I do have to say the
battle scenes looked really great for
the most part so like I said on my last
video I thoroughly enjoyed how they
opened up the episode there were some
great shots of the Starks Castle along
with all these different armies that
came together to fight alongside one
another against a common enemy but then
there was complete silence that fell
over the entire battlefield I can only
imagine how terrifying it would be to
stand there just waiting for death to
appear out of the dark abyss it kind of
reminded me of looking into the ocean
during the middle
tonight it's very calm and peaceful but
you just know there are monsters lurking
in the shadows after a few moments
Melisandre slowly starts to appear out
of that darkness you have to wonder how
the hell did the army that did not see
her where did she come from this really
added to that ominous atmosphere that
set up these opening scenes of the
battle when Melisandre shows up and
ignites all their weapons it does give
everyone a bit of a confidence boost it
certainly had me excited because I
immediately wondered what else could she
do this is also when they started to
show some more signs that maybe Arya has
a bigger job in the battle than we
originally thought
as soon as Melisandre gets inside of the
castle her and Arya lock eyes for
several moments at the time I just
assumed it was because they recognized
each other from season 3 but Melisandre
obviously knew more than she was ready
to reveal at that time she had to wait
for the right moment to say something to
Arya otherwise they could have thrown
off the entire battle almost like a
butterfly effect
now when the battle does begin it's
complete chaos their battle strategy
goes right out the window like we all
knew that it would Daenerys essentially
did what John did during the Battle of
the bastards just like when John saw
Rickon about to die Daenerys got on her
dragon when she saw all of her men
starting to die it really did look and
feel amazing though when Daenerys
started to lay down dragon fire on the
thousands of White's charging ahead it's
safe to say the dragons really do make a
difference now I was actually very
surprised that ghost made it out of the
opening charge alive I don't recall ever
seeing him for the rest of the battle
but he was in the trailer for the next
episode so I know he did make it as soon
as I saw him next to Jorah Mormont I
thought he would die for sure but he did
live to fight another day this would
become a common theme throughout the
entire episode because they did not
really kill off as many characters as
they probably should as far as I could
see they had all the main characters
standing right at the front of the lines
other than the ones that were on the
battlements all of these main characters
were taken on an overwhelming amount of
whites I just can't see how they all
would have made it out of that fight as
much as I like Samwell there was really
no reason why he should have made it out
of the battle we know Sam cannot fight I
saw him get overwhelmed by
several times over the course of the
episode it happened on the battlefield
then on the battlements then once again
in the courtyard
the fact that he was able to fend off
that many outnumbered attacks is kind of
ridiculous I thought they would work
around this by having Sam do something
else during the battle it did not make a
lot of sense to have Sam survive when so
many other battle-tested soldiers are
getting killed left and right you can
almost say the same thing about Jaime
Lannister now we all know he was one of
the greatest swordsman in Westeros
however that was before he had his hand
cut off ever since then Jaime struggles
to even hold a sword how the hell did
Jaime survive the battle aren't they
facing the most dangerous threat
Westeros has ever known yet very few
from the main cast actually died since
they did have Jaime and Sam survived the
battle I can only assume they have a
bigger part to play later otherwise why
are they keeping them around Jaime will
most likely see Cersei Lannister again
now I did think it made sense for
characters like Arya Brienne and Sandor
Clegane to survive the battle we know
they are some of the best fighters in
Westeros today it also made sense for
beric Dondarrion to die during the
battle I always said he would sacrifice
himself only he did it for Arya instead
of saying dorkly gain we later find out
from Melisandre why Barrack wanted to
save Arya now we did see some other
minor characters die like dollar aside
and Lyanna Mormont but the two that had
the biggest emotional impact on me were
Sir Jorah Mormont and Theon Greyjoy
although he was sort of a secondary
character Jorah Mormont is one of the
few characters that was still alive from
the opening episode of the series I did
like the way that they ended his story
he always said he would die for Daenerys
and that's exactly what he did at a time
when she needed someone there the most
Jorah came out of nowhere to save his
Khaleesi he definitely went out like a
soldier now unfortunately since we saw
Jorah Mormont and Lyanna Mormont die
this very well could be the end of their
house Lyanna Mormont smother died when
fighting for Robb and Leona died
fighting for Jon this was obviously not
a very big family but they did make a
big impact on the show now in a crazy
turn of events I think Theon Greyjoy had
one of the best character our
in the show he never did face off
against his uncle you're on like I had
hoped but I really can't think of a
better ending for that character we saw
John forgive him last season then we saw
him in songs I become very close then we
saw him save his sister and she forgave
him then of course for his final scene
bran stark thanked him and he said that
he was a good man
like I said in some of my other videos I
know some of you still hate Theon
Greyjoy but I did get very emotional
during his last few scenes I also want
to mention their music they play during
that final scene I thought it was
outstanding it did kind of remind me of
the light of the seven only this one was
a little more sombre now before I do
start talking about the final scene let
me go back just a little bit there was a
moment during all the chaos that I
thought was very powerful right before
they liked the trenches on fire we see
grey worm have to make one of the
toughest decisions of his life he can
see the whites are forcing his men all
the way back to the trench he has to
make the decision do I wait and see if
they can hold him off or do I collapse
the small bridge and sacrifice all of
those men I really felt the impact of
that moment and I also want to say I was
very impressed by the unsullied during
the battle these soldiers are some of
the bravest son of a [ __ ] I've ever
seen they continued to stand their
ground even in the face of death
it was actually kind of inspiring now
even though most of the battle plans
were a complete disaster I did like that
they were able to convey that in some
way now I am a little concerned about
Danish dragons we obviously saw them in
the trailer for the next episode but
they were getting their asses kicked a
few times in that episode when John and
Danny were fighting the night king in
the sky we could see visera on digging
his claws right into Reagan's chest he
was also getting his neck ripped apart
as well I'm wondering how much longer he
could hold up in the future battles I'm
also not entirely sure how much damage
dragon suffered when all those whites
were climbing all over him like a crazy
flea infection it looked like hundreds
of whites were on him and I saw they
were also stabbing and cutting him at
the same time I remember seeing drug on
at the end of the episode next to Danny
and Jorah Mormont but I just hope that
they have enough time to recover before
they're thrown into battle again they
will eventually fight sir
but maybe a couple months or so goodbye
before it actually happens John and
Danny will eventually relocate to
Dragonstone so maybe they can take a
break during that time I don't know but
I do know they definitely need it right
now
now I want to make my way to the final
scene this was one of those moments that
damn near broke the internet this has
completely divided the fan base which I
think does suck unfortunately some fans
like to instantly go to attack mode
whenever someone has a difference of
opinion so hopefully if there is a
debate in the comment section of the
video try to keep it respectful now
let's start when John almost has a
chance to face the night king one versus
one after we see the night Kings dumbass
fall off of his dragon and Danny tries
to burn him with gurgaon John sees it as
an opportunity to go after the night
king not only was the own foot but damn
near all the whites around him were dead
this is when I thought we would finally
see John get to challenge the night king
I can't even begin to tell you how badly
I wanted this in that moment John knew
that the night king was heading straight
for the godswood all he basically had to
do was walk across the courtyard and he
would have been there within a few
minutes I actually think the night king
was scared to fight John in a sword
fight he already knew that John had some
kind of a special weapon in order to do
that so instead of accepting the
challenge he raised the whites to keep
John at a safe distance
not only did that occupy John but it
also kept Jaime Brienne and Jorah
Mormont busy now they were surrounded by
their own men everyone that had a
Valyrian steel weapon was now completely
screwed they were surrounded by whites
while the night King had a straight shot
for the godswood the only character who
had a Valyrian steel weapon that was
unaccounted for at that time was Arya
Stark because she was still inside a
Winterfell so the night king raises the
dead
Dany saves John then it gives John
another opportunity to get the night
king and save bran
now this is where things actually get
interesting I know there were some fans
that had issues with how the scene
worked out but I started to appreciate
it more after I watched it a second time
and I will tell you why when Jon Snow
enters the courtyard all he has to do is
make it to the other side then he's
basically less than a hundred yards away
from getting to
night king and brand at this moment John
already knows the night King has a head
start not only does he know the night
King has a head start but he also knows
the night king isn't getting slowed down
by anything because the whites are all
in his side so John only has minutes or
maybe even seconds to get through all of
this chaos to try to get to the night
king before he kills bran
every second John has slowed down as
another step closer the night king is to
killing brand
unfortunately for John this courtyard he
needs to make it across is completely
covered in whites he sees Samwell Tarly
on the verge of getting killed but he
has to make a very tough decision I
don't even have two seconds to help Sam
or else bran is dead I have to leave my
friend for dead or else we're all
finished we get different shots of all
the chaos in the small confined area
Jamie Lannister is about to die Brienne
one of the greatest fighters in Westeros
is about to die the crypts of Winterfell
which are right under John are coming
alive at this moment Daenerys and Jorah
Mormont are getting surrounded right
outside of the gate it looks like John
is our only chance if he doesn't get
across this damn courtyard everyone he
has ever known or loved is dead he has
to work his way through dozens of whites
just to get from one area to the next
John has to use every last ounce of
energy he has just to make it there just
when it looks like he will make it in
time Vasari on comes crashing down into
the damn courtyard to block his way if
he can somehow get around that dragon he
might be able to make it all he has to
do is get around the dragon but
vissarion is not about to let that
happen John makes several attempts but
he has to fall back and take cover every
single time he cannot and will not make
it around this area on John is now in
complete exhaustion he knows he can't
make it he's tired he's weak he's
bleeding from all over his body the
dragon is just too damn big he's
finished he can see the finish line but
he knows he will never cross it he is so
close to getting to bran he could
probably smell the damned God's wood but
he now knows the night king has already
made it there and it's too late bran is
most likely already dead when John
finally stands up and screams in the
dragon's face some
fans thought it was ridiculous why would
John do that how could that possibly
help him kill the dragon or get to the
night king well this is what it looks
like when you know you are defeated John
screaming in the face of the dragon is
all of his anger all of his exhaustion
all of his pain all of his frustration
all the time he spent in the Nights
Watch leading up to this moment all the
sacrifices he has made to ensure that he
could save the realm he died to bring
the people together to stop the common
enemy but in the end not even that will
be enough I see this as an emotional
breakdown John knows it's over but if
he's gonna die then he wants to go out
standing on his feet I thought it was a
great moment after watching it again now
we go back to the godswood the night
king stops right in front of bran and
for a moment they are making eye contact
with one another but then brain lowers
his eyes to the night King's chest then
he raises them back up to make eye
contact again I think bran was looking
right at the area where the dragon glass
was inserted into his body then it's
almost as if arya gets shot out of a
cannon because she comes out of nowhere
to surprise the hell out of the night
king and the millions of fans watching
across the globe like i said in my last
video where I gave my initial thoughts I
was not expecting that to happen now I
knew something had to happen because I
could not see them ending the episode by
having the night King kill bran out of
all the different scenarios that were
running through my head in the moment
none of them involved Arya coming at the
night King quite like this if they were
trying to shock me then they definitely
accomplished that I thought the night
king was about to kill Arya then I
thought his brain about to stab the
night king when his back is turned I
wasn't sure what was about to happen
next I was on the edge of my seat the
entire time if you've seen my videos
then you probably could have guessed I
would have liked to see John and the
night King face off against each other
ever since their stare down at hardhome
their second stare down beyond the wall
I thought it was leading to an epic
showdown between John and the night king
I was highly anticipating getting to see
how well the night king could do in a
sword fight but obviously we did not get
that we did not get any more flashbacks
from bran Stark and we did not learn
anything from the books Samwell took for
the citadel that was very disappointing
because I was hoping to learn more about
the night King and/or the White Walkers
now obviously this show is not over yet
maybe we can still find out more
information before everything is all
said and done even though I did want to
see Jon Snow fight the night King I did
also say that if someone else were to
kill the night king besides Jon then I
would want it to be someone from
Winterfell Arya Stark would be the next
best option because sons that cannot
fight whatsoever and bran really can't
do much either I wanted it to be Jon
but Arya is not a bad second option I
have now seen the episode three times
and each time I watch it I find
something new that I like about it I'm
actually glad that I waited to make the
breakdown video because I did not want
to react off with just my emotions after
the episode ended I wanted to take some
time to think about how the episode
unfolded and what it means for the
future of the show so we shall see how
things go from here on out let me know
what you thought about the episode
anyways thank you all very much for
watching the video as always I really
appreciate that and I also want to thank
everyone for supporting the channel I
hope you have a great day I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you